this is our list of the top 10 films to
see at the 2014 Sundance Film Festival
number 10 white bird in a blizzard
written and directed by Gregg Araki
based on the acclaimed novel white bird
in a blizzard tells the story of Kat
Connors a young woman whose life has
turned upside down by the sudden
disappearance of her beautiful ending
matic mother Iraqis films always pack a
punch
and we're hoping his newest film will
give festival goers a good reason to be
out of the inevitable cold of Park City
Utah number nine the guest
directed by Adam Wingard still
struggling over the loss of their oldest
son Caleb in the war in Afghanistan the
Peterson family finds some solace when
an unexpected visitor knocks on their
door wing guard and frequent
collaborator writers Simon Barret are
known and horror circles for the VHS
films and last year's you're next the
guest is one of the spotlights and Sun
dances midnight lineup number eight
Kumiko the treasure hunter directed by
David Zellmer a lonely Japanese woman
becomes convinced that a satchel of
money buried and lost in a fictional
film is in fact real the fictional film
in question is none other than the Coen
brothers Fargo the subject matter sounds
right up any film buffs Ali and we think
this could lead into an unlikely
franchise of finding the cash stashes
from every Coen Brothers film number 7
mister Leos Carax erected by Tessa Lewis
Salome this documentary dives into the
poetic and visionary world of an artist
who was already a cult figure from his
very first film punctuated by
interviewed and unseen footage this
documentary is most of all a fine-tuned
exploration of the poetic and visionary
world of Leos Carax alias mr. X number
six God's pocket directed by John
Slattery a guy named Mickey gets in over
his head when he tries to cover up the
accidental death of his stepson this is
the directorial debut of John Slattery
outside of a handful of
so we're and he plays Roger Sterling as
a bonafide actor he should have no
problem wrangling a cast consisting of
Philip Seymour Hoffman John Turturro
Richard Jenkins Christina Hendricks and
Caleb Lander Jones number five hits
written and directed by David Cross the
film takes place in a small town in
upstate New York populated by people who
trade in unrealistic expectations this
is the feature-length directorial debut
of cross who fans of American comedy
know well from mr. show and Arrested
Development number four the voices
directed by Marjane Satrapi
Ryan Reynolds plays a disturbed factory
worker who hears advice from his pet dog
and cat this odd premise comes to us
from Iranian director Marjane Satrapi
has been on our radar since her dazzling
debut Persepolis number three life
itself
directed by Steve James in 2013 we lost
Roger Ebert arguably the nation's
best-known and most influential movie
critic this biographical documentary is
directed by Steve James 2014 also marks
the 20th anniversary of his beloved film
booth Dreams number 2 a most wanted man
directed by Anton Corbijn a Chechen
Muslim illegally integrates to Hamburg
where he gets caught up in the
international war on terror after many
years directing music videos Corbin made
the jump to feature films but 2007's
control followed by 2010 the American a
most wanted man will be his biggest film
to date and one of the major premieres
at Sundance this year number one the
raid to Baron Dahl written and directed
by Gareth Evans immediately following
the events of the original the raid two
tracks officer Rama has he is pressure
to join an anti-corruption task force to
guarantee protection for his wife and
child
with the raid Evans and his talented
cast of martial artists turned actors
raised the bar for the action genre of
what we've heard and seen of the raid -
with any indication he plans to kick
that bar to the curb that's our list for
the top ten films to see at the 2014
Sunday
film-festival comment below to let us
know what you're most excited for in
thanks for watching
you